so let's say that i am a drug company
and i have come up with a medicine that
i think will help folks with diabetes
and in particular i think it will help
reduce their hemoglobin a1c levels and
for those of you who aren't familiar
with what hemoglobin a1c is i encourage
you we have a video on that on khan
academy but the general idea is if you
have high blood sugar over roughly a
three month period of time
high
blood sugar
and i could say high average blood sugar
you're going to have a high a1c
a high hemoglobin a1c level and if you
have a low
average blood sugar over roughly a three
month time you're going to have a lower
hemoglobin a1c
so if taking the pill seems to lower
folks a1c levels
more than is likely to happen due to
randomly or due to other variables well
then that means that your new pill might
be effective at controlling folks
diabetes so in this situation what we're
trying to when we're constructing an
experiment to test this we would say
that whether you're whether or not you
are taking the pill this is the
explanatory variable
and the thing that it is affecting the
thing that you're hoping has some
response in this case you want to the
a1c levels are your indicator of whether
it is help controlling the blood sugar
we call that the response variable
that right over there
is
the
response
variable
so how are we actually going to conduct
this experiment
well let's say that we have a group of
folks
let's say that we have been given a
group of 100 folks who need to control
their diabetes
so 100
100 people here who need to control
their diabetes and say all right
well let's take half of this group and
put them into
i guess you say a treatment group and
another half and put them into a control
group and see if the treatment group the
one that actually gets my pill is going
to
improve their a1c levels in a way that
seems like it would not be just random
chance so let's do that so we're going
to have a control group
so this is my control group
control
and this is the treatment group
this is
the
treatment
treatment group and you might say okay
we'll just give these folks the
treatment group the pill and then we
won't give the pill that i
i created to the control group
but that might introduce a psychological
aspect that you know maybe the maybe the
benefit of the pill is just people
feeling hey i'm taking something that'll
control my diabetes maybe that
psychologically affects their their
blood sugar in some way and this is
actually possible maybe it makes them
act healthier in certain ways maybe that
makes them act unhealthier in certain
ways because like oh i have a i have a
pill to control my my diabetes my blood
sugar i can go eat more sweets now and
it'll control it and so to avoid that in
or in order for just the very fact that
someone says hey i think i'm taking a
medicine i might behave in a different
way or might even psychologically affect
my my body in certain way
what we want to do is give both groups a
pill and we want to do in a way that
both neither group knows which pill
they're getting
so what we would do here is we would
give this group a placebo
a placebo and this group would actually
get the medicine
the medicine but those pills should look
the same and people should not know
which group they are in and that is a
when we call when we do that that is a
blind experiment
experiment
now you might have heard about
double-blind experiments well that would
be the case where not only does the not
only do people not know which group
they're in but even their physician or
the person who's administering the
experiment they don't know which which
one they're giving they don't know if
they're giving the placebo or the the
actual medicine to the group so let's
say we want to do that so we're gonna we
could do
double
double blind experiment so even the
person giving the pill doesn't know
which pill they're giving and you might
say well why is that important well if
the physician knows it might or the
person administering
or interfacing with the patient
they might give a tell somehow they
might not put as much emphasis on the
importance of taking the pill if it's a
placebo they might
by accident give away some type of
information so to avoid that type of
thing happening you would have a you
could do a double blind and there's even
some people talk about a triple blind
experiment where even the people
analyzing the data don't know which
group was the control group and which
group was the treatment group and once
again that's another way to avoid bias
so now that we've kind of figured out we
have a control group we have a treatment
group we're using a1c as our response
variable so we would want to measure
folks a1c levels their hemoglobin a1c
levels before
they get either the placebo or the
medicine and then maybe after three
months we would measure their a1c
after but the next question is how do
you divvy these hundred people up into
these two groups
and you might say well i would want to
do it randomly and you would be right
because if you didn't do it randomly if
you put all the men here and all the
women here well that might
you know first of all sex might explain
it or the behavior
of men versus women might might might
explain the differences or the the not
the non-differences you see in a1c level
if you get a lot of people of you know
one age or one part of the country or
one type of dietary habits you don't
want that so in order to avoid uh having
an imbalance of some of those lurking
variables you would want to randomly
sample and we've done multiple videos
already on ways to randomly sample
so you're going to randomly sample and
put people into either groups
you know a very simple way
of doing that you could give everyone
here a number from 1 to 100 use a random
number generator uh
to do that and then you know if well or
or you could use a random number
generator to pick 50 names to put in the
control group or 50 names to put in the
treatment group and then everyone else
gets but gets put in the other group now
to avoid a situation you know just
randomly by doing a random sample
you might have a situation where
there's some probability that you
disproportionately have more men in one
group or more women in another group and
to avoid that you could do really a
version of stratified sampling that
we've talked about in other videos which
is you could do what's called a block
design for your random assignment where
you actually split everyone into men and
women and it might be 50 50 or it might
even be you know just randomly here you
got you know 60 women
60 women and
40 and 40 men and what you do here is
you say okay let's let's randomly take
30 of these women and put them in the
control group and 30 of the women and
put them in the treatment group and
let's put randomly 20 of the men in the
control group and 20 of the men in the
treatment group and that way someone sex
will is less likely
to to introduce bias into what actually
happens here so once again that doing
this is called a is a block design
really a version of stratified sampling
block design and there might be other
lurking variables that you want to make
sure it doesn't just show up here
randomly and so you might want there's
other ways of randomly
now once you do this you see what was
the change in a1c if you see that hey
you know the
the the change in a1c or well one if you
see there's no difference in a1c levels
between these two groups and you're like
hey there's a good probability that my
pill does nothing even and once again
it's all about probabilities there's
some chance that you're just unlucky and
it might be a very small chance and
that's why you want to do this with a
good number of people and as we
forward our statistics understandings we
will better understand at what threshold
levels do we think the probability is
high or low enough for us to really feel
good about our findings but let's say
that you do see let's say that you do
see an improvement
you need to think about is that
improvement
could that have happened due to random
chance or is it very unlikely that that
happened due purely to a random chance
and if it was very unlikely that it
happened due purely to random chance
then you would feel pretty good at other
people when you publish the results
would feel pretty good about your
medicine
now even then you know science is not
done
you're no one will say that they're 100
sure that your medicine is good there
still might have been some lurking
variables that we did not that our
experiment did not uh properly um uh
adjust for that just when we even did
this block design we might have
disproportionately gotten randomly older
people in one of the groups or the other
or people from one part of the country
in one group or another so there's
always things to think about and the
most important thing to think about even
if you did this as good as you could
you still
some random chance might have given you
a false positive or a you know you got
good results even though it was random
or false negative you got bad results
even though it was even though it was
actually random and so a very important
idea in experiments and this is in
science in general is that this
experiment you should document it well
and it should be
it should be it should we is that it
the the process of replication other
people should be able to replicate this
experiment and hopefully get consistent
results so it's not just about the
results it's your experiment design
other people should
it should be
should be an experiment that other
people could and should replicate to
reinforce the idea that your results are
actually true and not just random or
just due to some bad administration of
the actual experiment